how do you prevent you know some of the
amazing reactors that you're designing
how do you prevent from destroying all
human civilization in the process what's
the safety protocols Fusion is
um interesting because it's not really
directly weaponizable because what I
mean by that is that you have you have
to work very hard to make these
conditions at which you can get energy
gain from from fusion
um and uh this means that the the when
we design these devices with respect to
application in the energy field is that
they you know you
while while they will because they're
producing large amounts of power and
they will have hot things inside of them
this means that they have like a level
of industrial Hazard which is very
similar to like you would have like in a
chemical processing plant or anything
like that any kind of energy plant
actually has these as well too
but the underlying under underneath the
core technology like can't be directly
used uh in in a nefarious way because of
the power that's being emitted it just
basically well if you try to do those
things typically it just stops working
so the safety concerns have to do with
just regular things that uh like
equipment malfunctioning uh melting of
equip like all this kind of stuff that
has nothing to do with Fusion
necessarily yeah I mean usually what we
worry about is the viability because in
the end we build pretty complex objects
to realize these requirements and so
what we try really hard to do is like
not damage those components which but
those are things which are internal to
the to the fusion device and and it's
this is not something that you would
um consider about like it would as you
say destroy human civilization because
that release of energy is just
inherently limited because of the fusion
process so it doesn't say that there's
zero so you asked about the other
feature for that it's safe so it is the
process process itself is intrinsically
safe but because it's a complex
technology you still have to take into
amount consideration aspects of the
safety so it produces ionizing radiation
instantaneously so you have to take care
of this which means that you Shield it
you think of like your dental X-rays or
or treatments for cancer and things like
this we we always Shield ourselves from
this so we get the beneficial effects
but we minimize the harmful effects of
those so there are those aspects of it
as well too